it was one of those art auctions that
made headlines this week at sotheby's
here in new york a self-portrait by
artist frida kahlo
sold for just under 35 million dollars
yep that's it right there it shows how
the works of women can command
incredible sums on the world market but
that hardly tells the whole story
anthony mason's back and joins us here
in the studio with more anthony good
morning good morning michelle in fact
that sky-high sale belies the status of
most women artists now and throughout
history they've traditionally toiled in
relative obscurity compared to their
male counterparts something many are
hoping will soon change
so these paintings were stained
in her early days as a painter the
pioneering artist audrey flack was
afraid to use her first name here's
flack
54. this is 1954
yeah and there's a flack
a flag
it took a while for me to do audrey
why
you didn't want to be judged as a woman
artist
how would you be judged
lesser
less important
flak's work evolved from abstraction to
photorealism in the 60s which was
radical at the time radical but like
most women artists flack who's now 90
has struggled to get as much attention
as her male colleagues
why did the women get left out of the
story they've always been left out of
the story 2 million is called gentleman
speed in the art world the story is
often written in the global auction
markets where between 2008 and 2019 the
works of pablo picasso alone sold for
more money than all female artists
combined and if you thought women were
making progress in museums well over the
past decade only 11 percent of
acquisitions and just 14 percent of
exhibitions were of work by women
artists
they are still greatly undervalued in
the art market in museums
including the mfa noni gadsden is a
curator at the museum of fine arts in
boston i thought you know it has to have
been better in recent years but it's not
no
and i was shocked i found the number
that there was 3 800 works of art by
women came into the mfa collection in
the last 10 years i thought that's
pretty good until i realized it was less
than 5
of all of our acquisitions how do you
feel about that oh horrified
completely horrified and dismayed
and
energized that this has to be a mission
in an exhibition running through next
weekend at the museum of fine arts the
mfa has dedicated an entire floor to
female artists how many artists are
represented nearly a hundred women take
the floor features accomplished artists
who've been given little attention like
meta warwick fuller she was the first
african-american woman artist to get a
government commission
as a sculptor in 1907 and lauren mciver
why have we not heard about her the
whitney did a show about her in 53 yeah
but she's disappeared again she may have
had attention during her day yeah but
somehow in the history books
she falls away in 1958 life magazine
called grace hardigan the most
celebrated of the young women painters
really she began painting in 1948 and by
1953 she was an absolute star she was in
the museum of modern art mary gabriel
author of the best-selling book 9th
street women about female artists of the
50s says they were ultimately eclipsed
by male stars like willem de kooning and
jackson pollock
collectors thought only men could be
great painters were were painters were
painters or sculptures worth investing
in so that's all the dealers that's all
the dealers sold and eventually by the
late 50s it was a man's story
in the 60s the pop movement created
american arts first mega stars andy
warhol and roy lichtenstein is there a
female pop artist
i'm sure there is
i can't name it right now that says a
lot yes it does
but in 2019 an exhibit at new york's
guggenheim museum showed that even an
obscure woman artist could be a big draw
when record crowds flocked to see the
stunning work of hilma of clint hilma of
clint is a swedish artist that was
working in the early decades of the 20th
century in stockholm tracy bashkoff
senior curator at the guggenheim says
clint's epic paintings pioneered
abstraction the inventor of abstract art
was thought to be vasily kandinsky
around 1910
but hilma off clint's work preceded his
but they were actually painted when in
1907 1907 yeah 1907 i mean nothing like
it from the time period does this
suggest we need to re-examine art
history yeah
it does yes
h.w jansen's history of art which first
came out in 1962
was long the bible the preferred
textbook when it was originally
published
there were no women in general no women
no women in any art history book
in 1980 audrey flack says she had an
unexpected encounter with the author's
son
and argued that american painter mary
cassatt should be included and he put
her in
yeah and he put me in
which was kind of nice
first women
how did that feel
felt great in the 80s flak began
exploring sculpture and as she showed me
in her studio in east hampton new york
later chose to portray strong women like
eve
she's a very heroic woman
and sexy
and daphne the wood nymph of greek
mythology
so i decided to make her hair tree roots
which i gathered from
east hampton storms
do you feel
seen
more now as an artist
i'm getting letters from former students
and from artists
mainly women of how much my work has
meant to them
and i'm like wow
how did this happen
it's very gratifying but she's still
waiting for a career retrospective show
in new york
i'm 90.
how much longer do i have to go you know
it's like that much
whose job is it to turn some of these
women into brand names
all of ours with exhibitions like women
take the floor at the museum of fine
arts curator noni gadsden says the
imbalance in art is only just beginning
to be righted what are we missing when
we leave women out
50 of the story
and there it is yeah
that exhibition women take the floor
runs through next weekend next sunday in
boston if you're in the area and you get
a chance go see it it's terrific
i have to say i was inspired to to
follow this story by mary gabriel's book
ninth street women yeah if you get a
chance it's a 600 page book it's a brick
but i could not put this thing down
because you discovered that really the
art movement in america when america
really came to prominence there were so
many women involved in making that
happen how do you flip this
you know it it's happening now in a lot
of places the whitney museum here in new
york right now has an amazing exhibit of
a young black woman jennifer packer
which i just stumbled on and blew my
mind museums are trying but you've got
centuries of imbalance to correct here
and the story is only starting to be
written some of it was that i was insane
when you talk about the books the books
on art that have been written you do
have to go back and start looking at it
was men that were taking this and
compiling the information
that's how you get some of that change
and audrey flack is 90. i know
the most amazing that's what 90 i hope
90 looks like for me yeah sharpest
attack still creating like crazy amazing
woman and a great steward for her
profession yes exactly and she's seen it
all she has i mean she's got stories she
literally got hit on by jackson pollock
she got amazing stories and but most of
all incredibly talented artists and the
beard came back yes that was a flashback
back to the anthony mason stages of
anthony